c'est l'heure tout de suite de notre
second débat des débat de de société
plus prospective vous le savez je vous
propose un mot pour le lancer sobriété
en pleine crise de l'énergie c'est celui
que le gouvernement a choisi pour nous
inciter à moins consommer à passer
l'hiver sans coupure d'électricité
comment Emmanuel Macron est-il passé des
critiques du modèle à miche c'était il y
a 2 ans tout juste à la sobriété
énergétique de cette rentrée c'est
Marion Vigreux qui nous rafraîchit la
mémoire au sein du gouvernement c'est le
nouveau mot d'ordre réussite du plan de
sobriété nécessitera la mobilisation de
tous j'appelle donc chacune à établir en
septembre son propre plan de sobriété et
pourtant souvenez-vous la musique
n'était pas tout à fait la même il y a
deux ans et j'entends beaucoup de voix
qui s'élève pour nous compliqué qu'il
faudrait relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains en revenant à la
lampe à huile je ne crois pas au modèle
à miche et je ne crois pas que le modèle
Amish permet de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine mais voilà
crise énergétique et climatique oblige
les discours changent et le vocabulaire
avec plus qu'un mot à la mode la
sobriété devient aussi une feuille de
route ce qu'on sait que si on arrive à
être au rendez-vous de la solidarité de
la sobriété c'est dans notre main les
entreprises mais aussi les particuliers
sont donc invités à faire des économies
d'énergie et si vous ne savez pas
comment vous y prendre voici quelques
conseils livré cet été par Olivier Véran
quand on part en week-end ou quand on
part en vacances on débranche un maximum
de prises électriques parce que sinon ça
continue de consommer de l'énergie et
notamment des branches son wifi on
baisse un peu la clim maintenant que les
températures sont amenées à diminuer
c'est aussi un geste qui fonctionne et
puis bien sûr on éteint les lumières
quand on n'utilise pas les pièces depuis
les discours se sont musclés et c'est
désormais une campagne publicitaire qui
est en préparation
et pour ce débat je vous présente tout
de suite mes invités Thierry Broze
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes expert
energy professeur à Sciences Po jade
Lingard bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste au pôle écologie de
Mediapart et Thomas verin que bonsoir
bienvenue directeur exécutif en charge
de la stratégie et de la prospective à
RTE les évidemment et rester à mes côtés
peut-être sur ce mot de sobriété je
commence avec vous tirer brosse est-ce
que vous direz que c'est une sobriété
subit celle que l'on vit aujourd'hui
subi par l'urgence l'urgence de la
guerre en Ukraine de la flambée des prix
de l'énergie oui alors pas l'urgence de
la gare en Ukraine puisque la crise
énergétique prédate de la guerre en
Ukraine oui elle est subie parce que
elle était heureuse dans les modèles des
analyses qui se sont trompés et comme
ils se sont trompés et bien on n'a pas
suffisamment de production énergétique
et donc on doit subir la sobriété et on
devra se serrer la ceinture pendant les
quelques prochaines années voilà vous
avez on nous explique on peut pas
allumer quatre feux à 19h pour faire la
cuisine on vous explique ce genre de
choses c'est bien une sobriété subie
quand vous dites la sobriété heureuse
qu'on nous avait promise et qui ne tient
pas c'est que cette référence à quoi je
fais référence à tous les modèles
scénaris qui nous expliquaient qu'on
allait demain consommer moins qu'on
allait qu'on pouvait fermer des
centrales nucléaires qu'on pouvait faire
des centrales thermiques parce que
demain de façon mystérieuse on allait
consommer la seule chose dont je suis
sûr tout le reste je prends un peu le
discuter la seule chose en suis sûr dans
une transition énergétique réussie c'est
qu'on va avoir besoin de beaucoup
beaucoup plus d'électricité pas cher
voilà on l'a pas et donc on va avoir une
une sobriété subie une transition
énergétique ratée et une décroissance
jade lingarde cette sobriété heureuse
j'imagine que c'est celle que vous que
vous prenez
comment vous réagissez à ce à
l'irruption là de ce mot dans le
vocabulaire politique depuis quelques
semaines
c'est un mot très important et qu'il
faut
faire attention à comprendre à recevoir
dans toute sa richesse en fait et dans
le sens où parler de sobriété est un
point de vue énergétique mais pas
seulement la sobriété comme un peu règle
de vie comme projet pourquoi pas d'une
société à un moment c'est fondamental
parce que c'est renverser la manière
dont on
regarde et on essaye d'organiser notre
économie et nos activités et c'est
partir des usages c'est partir des
besoins qui a une question politique
très ancienne et qui qui est très
importante et là où c'est un
renversement qui qui est très important
à elle me semble à faire et que et même
si c'est on le fait très tard en France
il faut le faire aussi maintenant c'est
que plutôt que de comme des monsieur
Bros il a raison de dire on se retrouve
acculé aujourd'hui avec des décisions
qui sont subies et un délai de décision
qui est beaucoup trop court pour qu'il
se passe d'une manière juste et
démocratique mais si on se dit à très
donnons-nous un peu plus de temps
puisque l'enjeu ne concerne pas
simplement le fait de passer cet hiver
mais de changer de société parce que
nous sommes en situation de dérèglement
climatique de désastre climatiques et
des Causses entendons ce qui se passe et
regardons ok exactement de quoi
avons-nous besoin en tant que société
quelles règles pouvons-nous nous donner
pour en décider démocratiquement et une
fois qu'on a à peu près essayé d'estimer
des besoins des usages de quelle
quantité d'énergie nous avons besoin
pour les fournir ces usages donc on voit
bien là on raisonne de manière
totalement différente que ce que fait
Emmanuel Macron ou la plupart de nos
dirigeants mais c'est ça que nous
demande la sobriété et c'est pour ça que
c'est important parce que ça permet de
repenser un modèle de société on va y
revenir évidemment en détail à la fois
sur le court terme comment passer
l'hiver et sur le long terme comment
atteindre cet objectif de la neutralité
carbone en 2050 Thomas verrinck c'est
justement ce que vous proposiez avec
RTE alors faut rappeler ce qui RTE c'est
le réseau transport de l'énergie c'est
ça
l'électricité voilà il faut être précis
et donc vous aviez proposé 6 scénarii si
scénarios pour atteindre cette
neutralité carbone si je schématise ça
va du 100% renouvelable à une parité 50%
nucléaire 50%
renouvelables est-ce que la sobriété
énergétique dans vos différents
scénarios elle est obligatoire alors
effectivement donc RTE c'est bien le
réseau de transport d'électricité donc
le réseau national avec l'équilibre en
temps réel du système et puis la mission
de prospective donner un certain nombre
d'éléments pour la prise de décision je
crois que il y a bien deux échéances de
temps il y a l'échéance de temps du
court terme cet hiver on a une crise
gaziaire européenne une crise de
production nucléaire française une
sécheresse avec un impact très important
sous l'hydraulique donc en fait on est
sur une situation qui est très
contrainte donc là il y a pas vraiment
beaucoup de choix sur la façon
célébrer le système et puis vous avez le
long terme 2050 la neutralité climatique
donc pour ça faut passer d'une société
qui dépend très largement des fossiles
65 70 % de notre énergie est fossile une
société dans laquelle il y en a plus du
tout en 2050 et beaucoup moins dès 2030
c'est-à-dire dans 8 ans dans la
trajectoire faut pas oublier le point de
2030 pour ça on a développé un certain
nombre de scénarios vous parlez des six
donc qui sont sur la partie production
où on dit on a le choix entre faire un
système nucléaire plus renouvelable ou
un système qui dépendra à terme
uniquement des énergies renouvelables et
puis on essaye de déterminer les
conditions qui sont associées à cela et
puis sur la consommation on joue sur
différents volets et on joue sur quoi
l'efficacité donc le fait de consommer
moins d'énergie mais à usage égal la
sobriété qui n'est pas la même chose
c'est-à-dire de réduire nos besoins et
donc nos consommations bien évidemment
il faut de l'électrification il faut
remplacer les énergies fossiles par de
l'électricité donc on des trajectoires
qui sont croissantes en électricité et
puis la réindustrialisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui
on importe beaucoup de biens si on
regarde la question de l'empreinte
carbone c'est-à-dire la les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui sont associés à
notre consommation mais il faut intégrer
les imports et donc la
réindustrialisation c'est aussi quelque
chose qui peut nous conduire à faire
augmenter nos consommations donc voilà
après par rapport à la question de la
sobriété le faire sans efficacité
énergétique c'est impossible le faire
sans sobriété c'est très difficile
Laetitia ce mot là de sobriété il est il
est un peu partout notamment dans la
bouche de tous les membres du
gouvernement oui oui et puis c'est le
contexte et c'est la rencontre d'une
obsession médiatique et d'une grosse
opération de communication de la part de
l'exécutif donc il n'y a pas une
interview sans que ce sujet de l'énergie
soit mis sur la table et sans que le mot
sobriété ne soit prononcé exemple ce
matin avec le ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire c'était sur France Inter
jusqu'à décembre pour mettre le
chauffage à Matignon ou à Bercy comme
dans le collège de ma fille qui va
permettre le chauffage apparemment avant
de descendre nous mettrons pas le
chauffage tant que la température ne
sera pas en dessous de 19 degrés la
température qui a été retenue cette 19
°c
donc vous verrez plus avec une cravate
mais avec un col roulé et je pense que
ce sera très bien que ça permettra de
faire des économies d'énergie de faire
preuve de sobriété c'est la manière la
plus efficace de passer l'hiver sans
avoir à couper l'énergie pour qui que ce
soit alors est-ce que ce type de
communication vous rappelle quelque
chose Thomas pas forcément
pendant le covid Jean Castex qui
demandait aux Français de laisser papi
et mamie dîner seul dans la cuisine
pendant les repas de Noël ça s'appelle
de la communication directe pragmatique
mais ce qui est intéressant dans cet
extrait que l'on vient d'écouter c'est
la question de l'auditeur dans la bouche
de Léa Salamé puisque l'auditeur
sous-entend finalement qu'il y a deux
poids de mesure et que le gouvernement
lui va mettre le chauffage à fond tout
l'hiver
principal obsession de l'exécutif ne pas
se mettre à dos l'opinion publique
lorsqu'il a tenu sa conférence sur sa
politique énergétique c'était le 5
septembre il a bien souligné
l'importance d'un plan de mobilisation
active d'un effort général de
l'administration de tous les secteurs de
l'économie et bien sûr des ménages
l'objectif c'est moins 10% de
consommation d'énergie mais cet objectif
avait été accompagné dans la bouche
d'Emmanuel Macron non pas d'une menace
mais d'une petite précision qui avait
son importance écoute on le pour moi ce
plan de sobriété c'est ce qui doit nous
éviter d'aller vers quelque chose qui
est plus coercitif et qui serait à ce
moment là un plan de sobriété de
renforcer voire de rationnement et qui
évidemment nous protégera une fine des
coupures et donc vous le voyez en
quelque sorte c'est par gradation le
premier étage de la mobilisation
générale c'est la sobriété volontaire
il veut donc éviter des mesures
contraignantes
on le fait tous ensemble parce que sinon
derrière il y aura des contraintes des
injonctions et forcément pour l'exécutif
une menace de révolte il faut éviter
absolument Thomas les manifestations
contre des par exemple des privations
qui seraient ressentis comme étant
complètement injuste il sait Emmanuel
Macron tous l'exécutif le sexe le
terrain social est bouillant en cette
rentrée les oppositions et les syndicats
la tiges depuis l'élection
présidentielle et les premières
manifestations on l'a dit tout à l'heure
commence donc cette semaine le mot
d'ordre au gouvernement c'est simple
c'est surtout de montrer l'exemple de
faire peur de pédagogie douce
d'accompagner pour créer encore une fois
un élan national mais surtout surtout
c'est d'éviter tout départ de fronde
est-ce que ça vous semble réaliste
Thierry brosse l'absence de mesure
contraignantes dans le contexte alors là
je pars du court terme on parlera du
long terme après alors je crois que dès
le début de la guerre en Ukraine j'avais
été un de ceux qui disait attention il
va y avoir un problème la crise
énergétique je l'ai écrit trade depuis
très longtemps et j'avais expliqué à
cette époque là il fallait une campagne
de propagande pour expliquer qu'on ce
qu'on pouvait faire qu'est-ce qu'on
pouvait pas faire c'est que ça serait
subi mais qu'il fallait le faire
on venait fin septembre la guerre a
commencé il y a bien longtemps la crise
énergétique c'était il y a 18 mois et le
ministre nous explique qu'il va mettre
un col roulé bon je suis pas sûr que ça
va changer beaucoup alors c'est cette
anecdotique moi je regarde les chiffres
vous savez je suis juste un analyse de
base je regarde les chiffres et quand on
les pays de l'Est les pays de la
Baltique ont rejoint l'Union européenne
on leur a demandé d'augmenter le prix de
l'électricité massivement et Christ et
gaz massivement c'était il y a très
longtemps c'était dans les années 2005
50% par an ça vous rappelle c'est un peu
différent du 15% qu'on voit et bien
quand on regarde les chiffres de la
demande dans ces pays-là la demande n'a
pas baissé en fait il y a eu une demi
baisse de la demande des consommateurs
résidentiels quelques
après pas tout de suite parce qu'encore
une fois le consommateur n'est pas un
trader le consommateur il va pas
s'adapter du jour au lendemain et là je
suis d'accord avec vous le conseiller en
l'occurrence oui bah enfin là il aura un
choix puisque sa facture va pas
forcément flamber et personne ira
vérifier chez lui à part si à part si
maintenant on regarde Linky mais
personne ira regarder chez lui s'il est
à 19 ou 20 ou 21 et encore une fois avec
Linky je suis pas sûr qu'on soit capable
de le faire mais enfin ça c'est aussi
une autre donc oui on est dans un
système où l'exécutif se retrouve dos au
mur en ayant pas prévu cela on nous
racontait quand même il y a quelques
temps qui avait pas y avoir de coupure
d'électricité ça je crois que c'était
avant l'élection présidentielle si je me
rappelle bien et voilà donc aujourd'hui
la dû réalité des faits là
jadin garde cette formule d'Emmanuel
Macron l'a entendu dans les titres on
l'appareil entendu là là la fin de
l'abondance quand vous l'avez reçu
c'est vrai c'est à dire que c'est c'est
vrai dans le sens où notre société a
vécu dans voilà sans en discuter sans
doute et sans doute sans que beaucoup de
gens s'en rendent compte mais dans une
forme de de
sentiment d'être exonéré des limites
des ressources naturelles des limites
planétaires comme on dit en écologie ce
qu'on appelle les limites planétaires ça
va être parce qu'il cause aujourd'hui le
dérèglement climatique l'acidification
des océans la fonte des glaciers
la disparition l'extinction massives
d'espèces donc des limites planétaires
en fait pour plein de raisons qui sont
liées à la fois au capitalisme à la
société de consommation à la manière
dont notre monde politique c'est
constitué de façon tout à fait distante
vis-à-vis de des autres êtres vivants on
était dans un dans un déni en fait de
l'impact de nos modes de vie et de nos
systèmes de production de richesse sur
le de la planète et donc si ça ça on
peut considérer que c'est une forme
d'abondance dans le sens où une
surabondance octroyer des moyens dont en
réalité on ne disposait pas donc ça
c'est récent non c'est poste secondaire
mondiale ben en fait ben non enfin
il faudrait spécifier de qui on parle
parce que là ce que je vous dis c'est un
tableau à très grande inégalités bien
sûr entre pays et bien sûr au sein de
notre société entre entre les ménages
mais en fait si vous regardez le
dérèglement climatique qui aujourd'hui
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui qu'on voit
aujourd'hui massif et terrifiant il est
causé par les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre n'est-ce pas et ces émissions
de CO2 elles ont commencé massivement
dans les pays occidentaux avec la
révolution industrielle ça a commencé
avec à la fin du XVIIIe siècle à la fin
du XVIIIe siècle et au 19e siècle et en
fait si vous il y a les si vous regardez
ce qui était les discussions à l'époque
au moment de la Révolution française il
y a des discussions en France passionne
passionnées passionnés sur la
disparition des forêts et l'impact que
la disparition des forêts pourrait avoir
sur le climat on parlait pas de
changement climatique comme nous
aujourd'hui mais en fait la
compréhension d'un impact délétère des
sociétés humaines sur le climat et la
nature est très ancien simplement il y a
plein d'historiens et d'historiens qui
travaillent là-dessus c'est voilà et
simplement ce qui s'est passé c'est que
il y a eu la fabrication d'un déni de
cette réalité et que aujourd'hui en fait
la gravité du changement climatique elle
nous oblige à sortir de ce déni mais
encore une fois il y a des décennies
d'alerte ce qui est fort dommage on a
perdu beaucoup de temps et maintenant la
question c'est comment faire pour agir
dans la justice sociale et dans la
démocratie puisque plus le temps passe
moi il y aura des espaces pour en
délibéré démocratiquement alors vous
l'avez évoqué Laetitia il y a cet
objectif réduire de 10% notre
consommation énergétique d'ici deux ans
c'est le plan de sobriété é pratique du
du gouvernement
certains ont pris les devants je vous
propose un reportage tout de suite dans
ce sens public l'histoire de Margot le
portrait de Margot c'est une parisienne
qui adopte justement un mode de vie de
plus en plus sobre et moto et Xavier
Montel et Samia de chia pour limiter au
maximum son empreinte carbone Margot a
changé ses habitudes le chauffage n'est
allumé que quelques semaines par an dans
son logement parisien pourtant mal
isolée la vaisselle se fait à l'eau
froide et parfois même la douche j'ai
commencé à prendre des douches froid
dans mai dernier et là jusqu'à septembre
je continue à le faire donc je pense que
je vais pas tarder à rallumer parce
qu'il commence à faire frais dehors le
froid s'annonce tant mieux c'est
peut-être un bon moyen de stocker sa
nourriture au frais dans le garde-manger
qui donne sur l'extérieur dans l'idée
cet hiver ce qu'on aimerait bien c'est
pouvoir débrancher le frigo et mettre
tout dedans et tester un petit peu voir
ce que ça peut faire puisque le frigo
consommait énormément donc dans une
démarche de sobriété énergétique ce
serait ça serait pas mal d'arriver à le
faire donc ça va être un test la
démarche de sobriété de Margot va bien
au-delà des économies d'énergie ça c'est
des vêtements que j'ai acheté en
friperie donc la plupart des pulls mais
j'ai aussi des jeans voilà plus aucun
vêtement neuf n'entre dans sa garde-robe
elle n'achète que de la seconde main
dans des friperies j'ai eu un déclic sur
la surconsommation et je me suis rendu
compte aussi de tout ce qu'on a acheté
et qui était pas nécessaire typique les
vêtements en fait on a déjà enfin moi
j'ai déjà énormément de vêtements qui me
servent au quotidien et j'ai pas besoin
de beaucoup plus la démarche c'est de
moins consommer en fait de se détacher
aussi de tous ces messages de la fast
fashion qui nous pousse aussi à acheter
toujours plus toujours un modèle un peu
différent alors qu'on soit on a des
choses qu'il nous faut le déclic a eu
lieu il y a deux ans lors d'un voyage
d'études je suis parti en Erasmus à
Berlin j'ai rencontré aussi des gens
complètement différents qui avaient déjà
adopté des modes de vie un peu plus
sobre et donc je me suis dit que ça
serait pas mal de tester et en rentrant
il y a eu la période covid confinement
donc tout était à l'arrêt je me suis
posé beaucoup de questions j'ai commencé
à beaucoup m'informer et ça aussi changé
complètement ma façon de voir les choses
et ma trajectoire aussi de vie un
changement qui implique certains
renoncements comme les vacances en avion
c'était vraiment quelque chose de très
ancré toutes les vacances en famille on
avait vraiment l'habitude de prendre
l'avion de voyager j'étais hyper
privilégiée de ce point de vue là et du
coup bah maintenant si je souhaite
complètement révoluer cette période là
quand j'ai vraiment eu un déclic
vis-à-vis de l'avion et du congé
d'arrêter de le prendre donc là ça se
fait déjà deux ans que je l'ai pas pris
cet été elle a refusé de partir avec sa
famille à Tahiti un choix difficile à
comprendre pour ses parents mais
désormais elle préfère partir moins loin
et prendre le train on peut voyager
différemment en fait et ça m'a permis
aussi de redécouvrir un lien au voyage
complètement différent et du coup bah là
c'était par exemple on est parti à
Berlin donc là c'est juste pour vous
montrer on a pris une dizaine de trains
différents et on a fait toutes les gares
dans la campagne
dans la campagne allemande et c'était
hyper sympa en fait bon on a mis une
journée de voyage donc c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus long et mais ça permet de
prendre son temps de découvrir aussi
d'autres choses sur le chemin et en
ayant un impact hyper réduit on a fait
quand même de très bonnes vacances
depuis deux ans sa vie a changé mais la
jeune femme ne vit pas cela comme une
contrainte c'est pas si difficile de
faire les efforts au quotidien mais ça
reste un coup d'épée dans l'eau si
derrière on aligne pas ce qu'il faut au
niveau des mesures qu'elle soit
politique économique il faut qu'il y ait
aussi une prise de conscience globalisée
que ce soit pas juste que ça va pas
juste sur les individus et les citoyens
en tant qu'on consommateur individu au
quotidien mais qui est aussi que ça se
répercute en fait sur toutes les sphères
de la vie publique à 24 ans elle
envisage à terme de quitter Paris pour
s'installer en milieu plus rural
cultiver un potager et aller plus loin
dans sa démarche de sobriété
si tout le monde suit l'exemple de
Margaux on atteint facilement les 10% de
baisse d'ici deux ans oui ou non oui
certainement la question c'est est-ce
que démocratiquement tout le monde est
prêt à suivre ce chemin-là moi encore
une fois je suis prêt à ce qu'on
débattre démocratiquement de cette
question là encore une fois quand je
regarde les chiffres je vois pas ça donc
oui il y a quelques personnes qui ont
cette étude là c'est souvent des
personnes assez visibles pas pas très
nombreux quand même parce que je suis
pas sûr parce que si on veut regarder
les 10% que nous demandent de faire le
Président c'est l'équivalent d'un
confinement covid c'est ça qu'il faut un
peu comparer donc la question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes décidé à avoir un
nouveau confinement c'est une question
la période qui est donnée donc là mais
10% de baisse c'est beaucoup vous avez
un confinement voilà après oui vous
aurez le droit de sortir votre chien de
temps en temps mais c'est ça la question
qu'il faut qu'il faut poser Thomas verin
est-ce que c'est réaliste ambitieux moi
10% en 2 ans
- 10% en 2 ans c'est certainement
ambitieux
par contre je pense qu'on a pour assurer
quand même les gens sur le fait qu'on
n'a pas besoin de tous faire comme
Margot pour y parvenir deux éléments le
premier c'est que on pense souvent
sobriété réserte résidentiel bon c'est
normal de penser au bâtiment parce que
le bâtiment c'est le secteur qui
consomme le plus d'énergie en France
alors celui qui émet le plus de gaz à
effet de serre sont les transports c'est
pas exactement la même chose mais celui
qui consomment le plus d'énergie c'est
le bâtiment donc c'est là où il y a
beaucoup de leviers par contre faut pas
penser que les bâtiments résidentiels
pas que les logements nous ce qu'on a
essayé de dire c'est que il y a des
économies d'énergie très importantes à
aller chercher dans les bureaux et que
on peut tout à fait essayer de faire
porter l'effort sur un certain nombre de
consommation dans le tertiaire sans
mettre le pays à l'arrêt ou sans forcer
les gens à se chauffer tous à 15 degrés
c'est pas du tout ça dont il s'agit
parce que dans les bureaux il y a des
gestes assez simples à faire par exemple
les weekends le soir etc absolument et
puis parce que la réglementation c'est
déjà aujourd'hui qu'on doit pas chauffer
des bureaux à plus de 19 degrés et qu'il
y a beaucoup de surface tertiaires qui
sont chauffés à plus de 19 degrés et
tout le monde le sait donc déjà si on
arrive à faire ça et comment contraindre
ces secteurs
sans quitterelle de tout le débat sur la
sobriété c'est comment on le met en
oeuvre quels sont quels sont les
mécanismes mais bon déjà on peut aller
chercher dans les bureaux la deuxième
chose c'est que dans le secteur que ce
soit dans les bureaux ou dans le ou dans
le ou dans les logements le secteur
l'endroit où on peut aller le plus
facilement c'est le chauffage Le
chauffage ce sont les volumes les plus
importants donc si jamais on arrive à
toucher quelques dogs 1 degré sur le
chauffage en général on peut continuer à
prendre sa douche sa douche chaude et
pour répondre à votre question sur
comment le faire vous avez cité nos
scénarios 2050 j'ai animé deux ans de
concertation la question sur la sobriété
elle est toujours clivante et elle est
toujours clivante sur la question de
comment on fait
est-ce que c'est juste une incitation
donc c'est un discours et on dit on peut
construire une société sobre c'est pas
la même mais simplement on va
s'apercevoir qu'on avait qu'on avait un
certain nombre de consommation qui était
superflu il y en a d'autres qui disent
bah il faut des dispositifs
contraignants donc on interdit un
certain nombre de comportements et puis
vous avez encore une troisième catégorie
qui disent les sons les prix augmenter
et puis les gens vont s'ajuster
automatiquement alors le problème c'est
que si on laisse les prix de
l'électricité augmenter massivement un
ça pose un problème de cohésion sociale
de ça pose un gros problème par rapport
à notre agenda climatique puisqu'on a
besoin de faire en sorte que
l'électricité se répande au détriment
des énergies fossiles donc là on a une
petite fraîcheur
on a un contrat d'une entreprise à à
chauffer à 19 c'est c'est difficilement
quand on est citoyen lambda de on ne
comprend pas pourquoi on peut pas
contraste
une personne privée c'est la même chose
il peut y avoir un certain nombre de
contrôle et en tout cas en ce moment
depuis le début de l'été il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises de fédération qui se sont
engagés à et puis qu'ils le font
pourquoi parce que la facture
d'électricité d'énergie est telle que il
y a pas le choix on va baisser le
chauffage et ça je pense qu'on peut y
arriver à Brive échéance on va continuer
de d'explorer en fait des des pistes à
court terme là en l'occurrence on
pourrait parler de déco gestes et je
propose à Quentin de nous rejoindre de
nouveau avec ce que propose
l'association négat c'est quoi alors
expliquez-nous c'est vrai qu'on a vu
l'initiative de cette association qui a
publié son rapport ce matin en ayez
effectivement et vous venez de le
rappeler que le premier poste de
consommation d'énergie en France c'est
le résidentiel avec 30% de la
consommation et donc il teste plusieurs
idées comme celle de réduire la
température de nos chauffages baisser 1
à 2 degrés permet d'économiser 8 à 16%
de la consommation du chauffage quant
aux petits appareils vous savez la box
wifi par exemple et bien il représente
tous ensemble au total 15% de la
[Musique]
on peut citer l'initiative de France
Télévisions et de TF1 voilà une météo de
l'électricité effectivement ça fait
suite à un partenariat avec RTE donc le
gestionnaire du réseau électrique en
France les chaînes vont afficher une
météo de l'électricité alors tous les
soirs on sait pas encore exactement très
bien comment ça va fonctionner cet hiver
mais en clair face au risque de blackout
des pictogrammes seront affichés vous
les voyez sur cette page lors des
bulletins d'informations spécifiques
vers c'est normal orange système est
tendu et les éco-gestes sont bienvenus
rouges les coupures sont inévitables je
cite si nous ne baissons pas à notre
consommation au final ce sont quatre
Français sur 5 qui auront accès à cette
information en temps réel direte Thomas
merci beaucoup Quentin est-ce qu'on peut
éviter échapper aux coupures
d'électricité cet hiver oui on peut on
peut alors déjà le diagnostic c'est
jamais maniquer un du risque sur
l'approvisionnement il y en a il y en a
toujours la question c'est de savoir
dans quelle proportion et j'aimerais
dire que
la vraie répercussion de la crise
énergétique actuelle c'est pas tellement
le risque de coupure c'est l'envoler des
prix c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui est
problématique pour notre agenda
climatique et pour notre tissu
économique mais si on regarde la
question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement on a publié il y a
une dizaine de jours un rapport qui
essaie de quantifier le risque et de
montrer quelles sont les solutions dans
les solutions bien évidemment il y a la
sobriété là je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord à court terme la sobriété
baissée un certain nombre de
consommation ça nous permet d'envisager
de manière beaucoup plus sereine l'hiver
que ce soit en gaz ou en électricité
d'ailleurs et puis ce qui le problème de
l'électricité c'est jamais un problème
de volume d'électricité parce que le
volume d'électricité on l'a ça peut être
un problème de pointe donc ce qu'on dit
c'est que en plus lors de certains
moments on pourrait
appelé à la mobilisation la mobilisation
des entreprises d'ailleurs en premier
lieu on est en train de signer avec elle
un certain nombre de deux partenariats
et puis de tous les citoyens pour que
des baisses volontaires de la
consommation se mettent en oeuvre et ça
ça nous permet de réduire
considérablement le risque et d'écarter
la perspective de coupure si jamais on y
parvient alors je voudrais que dans ce
débat on ouvre un chapitre consacré à
l'état de nos centrales et nucléaires et
la question de l'énergie nucléaire je
commence avec vous tirer Bros
quelle leçon vous tirez de moi j'ai dit
il y a deux jours on avait une émission
sur une thématique approchante que ça
devrait être en ce moment là je dors du
nucléaire français enfin on devrait
faire la démonstration que grâce au
nucléaire on passe cette crise plus
facilement que que d'autres pays c'est
pas du tout le cas non c'est pas le cas
malheureusement je crois que le
nucléaire comme on l'a délaissé pendant
des années évidemment on arrive aux
autres dans une situation où le
nucléaire n'est pas capable de répondre
à la demande vous avez raison ça devrait
être la renaissance du nucléaire
français et international mais encore
une fois moi je vois le nucléaire toutes
les énergies posent problème le
nucléaire en pose comme les autres mais
moi je suis comme vous je regarde ça aux
émissions de CO2 c'est la seule chose
qui m'intéresse et donc le nucléaire en
aimait pas donc à partir de oui mais un
produit beaucoup beaucoup moins et là on
peut être d'accord et donc sur sur ce
sujet là c'est la seule solution et et
moi et c'est là où on n'est pas d'accord
je pense que face à ça on aurait dû
construire beaucoup de centrales
beaucoup de renouvelables et ne pas dire
aux Français serez-vous la ceinture
c'est ça le problème alors effectivement
il y a un problème EDF il y a un
problème de l'incapacité à remettre ces
centrales en route rapidement il y a un
agenda qui est beaucoup trop optimiste
et qui fait que effectivement on va se
retrouver à devoir faire cette sobriété
subit je veux juste quand même revenir
sur les chiffres qui ont été donnés ça
m'intéresse ça m'interpelle toujours des
gens qui donnent des chiffres et ensuite
on admet que c'est l'étape d'évangile si
je fais la Somme de deux chiffres qui
ont été donnés 16% sur la baisse de
chauffage à 2 degrés c'est ce qui a été
dit et 15% sur si j'arrête mon wifi la
nuit c'est ça 15 + 16 ça fait 31% et ben
écoutez je suis prêt à être réévité ici
l'année prochaine et je suis et je serai
très content qu'on ait fait 3 %
d'économie 31% c'est totalement aberrant
donc vous dites que les chiffres de
Negawatt sont pas justes sont
impossibles à en fait mais vous prenez
des hypothèses telles que effectivement
enfin 2 degrés déjà voilà on peut
toujours dire mais moi même les
hypothèses se sont pas révélées mais 31%
enfin laissez croire aux auditeurs qu'on
va arriver à 31%, c'est c'est juste ça
n'a jamais été vu dans une faille Excel
encore une fois moi je regarde la data
la vraie la passer bon je reste sur le
nucléaire et je voudrais évidemment vous
entendre là-dessus parce que je vous
vous êtes pourquoi pour le scénario 100%
renouvelable dans dans de parler notre
invité et qui a proposé RTE il y a
quelques il y a quelques mois en janvier
dernier moi je pense que ce que je pense
n'a pas grand intérêt pour les gens qui
nous regardent mais ce que on constate
en tout cas c'est que certes l'énergie
nucléaire produit une électricité
beaucoup moins carbonée que la plupart
des autres sources d'énergie ça c'est
incontestable le problème c'est qu'elle
a d'autres problèmes c'est-à-dire que
c'est dangereux on a des enjeux de
radioactivité il y a quand même eu des
catastrophes nucléaires que tout le
monde a en tête Fukushima Tchernobyl etc
et on a un très gros problème de déchets
irradié dont on ne sait pas très bien
encore quoi faire on a ce gros projet à
Bure d'enfouissement profond qui soulève
tout un tas de problèmes qu'on a
peut-être pas le temps de de d'expliquer
ici mais en tout cas aucun pays aucun
pays aujourd'hui n'a trouvé de solutions
pérennes pour ces déchets nucléaires
donc l'idée de
substituer en pour fournir notre
électricité notre système actuel
par la
nucléaire me paraît en fait encore c'est
pas une histoire d'opinion
de RTE pardon de vous avoir interrompu
mais si on dit on se passe du nucléaire
comment on comment on s'en sort avec
100% d'énergie renouvelable
essentiellement on va dire alors il y a
pas cléolien et le
photovoltaïque il y a aussi hydraulique
et ça et ça pour le
couper on est dans une électrification
massive et on va en avoir besoin de plus
en plus d'électricité mais en fait il y
a des usages qui vont demander plus
d'électricité par exemple la voiture si
on se dit qu'on arrête les voitures
thermiques donc on arrête et sans diesel
et qu'on passe à un parc tout électrique
il y aura besoin de plus d'électricité
pour les voitures mais en revanche il
faudra réduire les consommations
d'électricité pour autre chose par
exemple le l'exemple du résidentiel et
des logements donner tout à l'heure
par les scénarios RTE il est il est
intéressant parce que même si on
substitution remplace les chaudières à
gaz dans plein de logements aujourd'hui
par des pompes à chaleur à l'électricité
enfin pardon c'est on dit un peu
technique si vous le faites d'avoir un
ça consomme moins d'énergie la pompe à
chaleur que la centrale que la centrale
pardon que la chaudière à gaz et si vous
le faites dans des logements qui sont
mieux isolés vous allez avoir besoin de
consommer moins d'énergie en fait là on
va pas faire les scénarios de sobriété
de 100% renouvelables de la France en
deux minutes ce serait pas très sérieux
mais l'idée en fait
peut-être dû prendre d'ailleurs il y a
longtemps ce qu'il faudrait comprendre
ce qui est vrai que les personnes qui
nous regardent comprennent c'est qu'en
fait c'est tout un système qu'il faut
modifier et que ça saura vertueux si
tout un système est modifié et que par
exemple ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent de rénover
énergétiquement les logements c'est une
politique qu'on sait faire techniquement
qui est qui est bloqué pour plein de
raisons politiques et de blocages
institutionnels personnel etc mais on
sait faire ça va coûter beaucoup
d'argent mais ça va en rapporter
beaucoup au ménage parce que vous
consommez moins d'énergie et donc vous
dépensez moins d'argent dans vos
factures dans un logement bien isolé or
plus on est pauvre plus la part de ses
revenus qu'on qu'on donne enfin qu'on
dépense pardon qu'on dépense pour ces
consommations d'énergie plus elle est
importante donc c'est aussi une forme de
redistribution en fait il faut vraiment
penser de manière comme ça assez
symbiotique pardon c'est celui qui va
donner de l'argent pour rénover c'est
l'état ah bah là il faut cette échelle
là cette échelle là en fait
de milliards ou est-ce qu'on les met
est-ce qu'on les met d'abord dans la
rénovation
énergétique des logements est-ce qu'on
la met dans le programme de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires est-ce qu'on la met
dans un programme de d'énergie et donc
partir de là votre argument je sais pas
si vous allez pouvoir répondre
directement à la question Thomas verac
mais est-ce que la fermeture de
Fessenheim à l'aune de ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'était une c'était une
erreur alors je me doutais
un moment dans le débat et je vais le
dire la question de la fermeture de
Fessenheim elle est pas du tout en
termes de volume à la hauteur de ce dont
on parle pour le moment notre parc
nucléaire produisait il y a une dizaine
d'années 400 TW an cette année il va
produire entre 280 et 290 à watts par an
donc il fait plus de - 25 % Fessenheim
qui doit être compensé par le père de
Flamanville parce qu'en fait l'idée il y
a un trou mais c'était de le remplacer
c'est moins 2,5%. alors qu'on fait moins
25% donc c'est quand même pas du tout le
sujet c'est en fait c'est pas le sujet
ça nous arrangerait quand même là on a
appris aujourd'hui pardon interrompre
que l'Allemagne va prolonger deux
centrales nucléaires le ministre
allemand de l'économie l'a annoncé tout
à l'heure deux centrales nucléaires
monde reste opérationnels durant l'hiver
2023 et alors évidemment il dit en
disant de l'indisponibilité de nombreux
réacteurs français on est dans cette
situation là alors c'est un peu de nos
amis et voisins allemands j'attends
d'ailleurs de savoir dans quelle mesure
elles vont rester disponibles puisque on
parle d'une sorte de réserve moi je sais
pas ce que c'est qu'une centrale
nucléaire en observe mais bon attendons
de savoir comment ça se comment ça se
passe concrètement par rapport au débat
global première chose les scénarios
qu'on a construit conduisent pour
certains à réinvestissement plus ou
moins important dans l'appareil
électronucléaire pour d'autres vont à
terme vers du 100% renouvelable mais
entre 2050 et 2060 donc il s'agit pas de
toute façon de se passer de nucléaire
tout de suite la deuxième chose c'est
pardon je vous interrompre encore une
fois mais les investissements dans dans
en l'occurrence la question de des
nouvelles centrales nucléaires c'est
maintenant qu'il faut les faire ou alors
dans le développement massif des
énergies renouvelables c'est bien pour
ça qu'on a publié nos scénarios l'année
dernière
est une opération d'une telle ampleur
qu'elle nécessite des investissements
colossaux mais que ce soit dans le
nucléaire dans le renouvelable dans
l'efficacité énergétique et je vais vous
dire il y a un point commun entre ces
trois choses c'est une économie de
l'investissement on met beaucoup
d'argent au début et ensuite ça produit
des résultats
le nucléaire et les renouvelable ont une
structure économique en fait qui est
très qui est très proche ce qui est
intéressant rigolo c'est qu'on les
oppose tout le temps mais arrêtez d'un
point de vue économique ça ressemble
beaucoup donc nous ce qu'on a dit c'est
on part de 2005 ans on fait le
rétroplaning on s'aperçoit que de toute
façon il faut prendre beaucoup de
décisions maintenant
après la question du nucléaire elle
nécessite elle se pose pas dans les
mêmes termes que dans les années 70 ou
dans les années 80 on construit
aujourd'hui pas des réacteurs nucléaires
ou même rythme c'est un fait nous on a
construit nos scénario sur la base de
propositions des filières industrielles
et entre le début des scénarios et la
fin des scénarios il y avait quand même
d'ailleurs plus de réacteurs nucléaires
qui étaient proposés par certaines
filières qu'au début donc il y a eu des
bougies durant les deux ans de
concertation effectivement aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on a les éléments pour
prendre la décision et il me semble que
sur la base de sonner de nos scénarios
il y a un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été annoncées oui effectivement il
est sorti aujourd'hui le projet loi du
gouvernement d'accélération de la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires est sorti aujourd'hui étant
consultation auprès des associations
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
un projet loi très court quatre pages
assez technique et dont toute la
philosophie consiste à vouloir
simplifier les procédures
administratives notamment en urbanisme
notamment
abaisser la protection de certaines
espèces protégées
déroger à la protection de la loi
littorale donc en fait ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on voit que le
nucléaire conçoit pour ou contre il y a
pas de problème toutes les positions
sont légitimes mais la valoir aussi sans
doute ses principes pour les énergies
renouvelables parce qu'on est en urgence
et donc il faut peut-être simplifier
les règles et parce que sinon on voit ce
qui se passe par exemple si je prends le
renouvelable on voit ce qui se passe sur
certains projets d'éoliennes que ce soit
les éoliennes terrestres ou des offshore
avec avec des associations des riverains
qui s'y opposent et donc les projets
mettent une décennie aboutir alors que
ils auraient pu mettre deux ou trois ans
mais c'est pourquoi la Seigneur énergie
et celle qu'on dépense pas et c'est
pourquoi tant qu'on continue à avoir une
politique énergétique qui est
complètement obsédée par l'offre
toujours pensée comment on produit de
l'énergie plutôt que comme on
l'économise on se retrouve dans des
contradictions produire de l'énergie ou
protéger la biodiversité on a un moment
de crise écologique où on ne peut plus
se permettre cette arbitrage entre
climat et biodiversité effectivement
vous affirmez malheureusement qu'on est
sur le chemin d'aucun des scénarios
c'est que si on continue à notre rythme
sur les énergies renouvelables non
seulement on peut pas faire les
scénarios 100% renouvelables mais on
peut même pas faire la part renouvelable
des scénarios avec du nucléaire si on
continue à notre rythme sur le nucléaire
on peut pas faire les scénarios dans
lequel il y a réinvestissement dans le
parc nucléaire donc la question de
l'accélération bien sûr elle se pose la
question de ce qu'on peut faire sur la
demande elle est
omniprésente dans nos scénarios après
moi je peux vous dire que vous témoignez
au bout de deux ans il n'y a pas de
choses faciles il y a des gens qui
étaient pour le renouvelable
pas spécialement de qui était pour la
renouvelable et sobriété des gens qui
étaient pour le renouvelable sans
réflexion spécifique sur la sobriété et
des gens qui étaient pour le nucléaire
et la sobriété en même temps en fait
c'est le monde est pas binaire par
rapport à je pense qu'il faut les deux
en même temps Thierry brosse vous dites
on finalement depuis le début cette
crise énergétique il y a des décisions
qui auraient pu être prises et qui les
ont pas qui n'ont pas été oui enfin on
parlait des prix tout à l'heure mais si
les prix sont élevés c'est parce que les
traders le marché depuis 18 mois essaie
de crier au politique qui ne voulait
absolument pas l'entendre il y a une
crise énergétique et une crise
énergétique il y a pas besoin d'avoir
une feuille Excel pour savoir que ça va
durer 5 ou 6 ans si on trouve une
solution tout de suite mais
effectivement si il y a aussi une part
de de spéculation dans dans la situation
qu'on est en train de vivre bah écoutez
les prix ils sont hauts depuis 18 mois
donc le marché a raison vous avez moi je
suis un homme de marché le marché a
toujours raison donc et là il a prouvé
encore une fois rappelez-vous le
gouvernement français l'année dernière
nous expliquait que la crise allait
durer jusqu'à fin décembre puis après
jusqu’aux élections moi le marché c'est
pas ce qui donnait un des groupes futurs
c'était pas du tout comme ça et sur
l'investissement je voudrais t'amener en
évoquant que pour le moment on n'a rien
fait donc on n'est pas dans les scénaris
et deuxièmement la seule chose que les
gouvernements européens ont fait c'est
protéger les consommateurs donc on a
dépensé un demi trillion d'euros pour
protéger les conséquences il faut les
protéger je sais pas mais on a dépensé
un demi trillion d'euros au niveau de la
maille européenne pour protéger les
consommateurs je pense que l'argent
magique on est en train de voir sur les
marchés que ça va sterrir donc une fois
qu'il y aura plus d'argent magique on
verra comment on va faire pour les
autres investissements Jean garde il y a
une autre mesure qui a été tellement
symbolique c'est le fait de remettre en
service la centrale à charbon de de
Saint-Avold pour passer l'hiver là
encore et ça ça rejoint ce que vous
dites c'est à dire que on sait on est
dans des injonctions complètement
contradictoires en ce moment mais en
fait c'est très intéressant de vous
étiez cet exemple parce que je me
permets de citer encore un autre
historien Jean-Baptiste Fressoz qui
montre bien que en fait Hist les
énergies se sont toujours additionnées
c'est à dire qu'on pense aujourd'hui des
gens il y a une histoire un peu qui se
raconte de l'énergie qui consiste à dire
avant nos sociétés consommaient beaucoup
d'eau et de bois puis on est passé au
charbon puis on est passé au pétrole et
maintenant ce serait l'âge des
renouvelables ou du nucléaire en
fonction de comment si tu pars par
rapport à ça en fait c'est pas ça qui
s'est passé c'est tout s'additionne et
donc par exemple si vous regardez un
exemple qui le site l'Angleterre
aujourd'hui consomme au moins autant de
bois qu'au 19e siècle pourquoi parce que
les grosses centrales à charbon
l'Angleterre la Grande-Bretagne avait à
beaucoup de centrales à charbon on en a
beaucoup de centrales nucléaires ils
avaient beaucoup de centrales à charbon
historiquement pour produire leur
électricité elles sont aujourd'hui pour
des raisons climatiques fermées
remplacées par des énormes centrales
biomasse à bois qui consomment
énormément de bois donc en fait encore
une fois on a une vision parfois un peu
trop naïve un peu illusoire d'une
transition énergétique on ne
transitionne pas comme ça parce que
c'est le sens de l'histoire d'une
énergie à l'autre tout ça doit faire
l'objet de une décision politique forte
sans doute avec au départ de contraintes
et mais il faut bien se rendre compte
que l'écologie et la sobriété ce n'est
pas qu'un mot c'est une matérialité et
la matérialité du monde en fait elle
nous rattrape et ses énergies ben voilà
la centrale à charbon c'est pas étonnant
parce que le monde aujourd'hui continue
à utiliser énormément de charbon pour
produire les biens que nous importons en
France par exemple merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission je
vous dis à demain évidemment sur public
Senna et votre prochain rendez-vous
politique l'invité politique de la
matinale rien de Mancini reçoit
Jean-Philippe Tanguy le député
rassemblement national de la Somme belle
soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]